Das Podcast UFO Facts. Das Podcast UFO Facts. Das Podcast UFO Facts. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast Ufo mit Flo und Will und mein Name ist übrigens, übrigens, das dürfte auch mal erwähnt sein, Stefan Tietze. Ja, schön, dass wir hier zusammengekommen sind. Vielen, vielen Dank an Max für dieses fantastische Intro. Ja, der zweite Max in Folge, es sind die Max-Wochen gerade bei Das Podcast. Los Mochos! Los Mochos! Wir wollen alle Mucks dieser Welt hintereinander wegballern, damit wir einfach den Buchstaben, den Namen mal durch haben, damit auch die Nicoles...
Sind wir bei M jetzt schon? Wir sind bei M, danach kommt N, also alle Nicolz, Nikos, Neles, bitte gerne Intros einschicken, wir arbeiten da einfach mal durch. Ja, uns wurden die Steckdosen abgedreht. Richtig, wir werden sabotiert, diese Podcast-Uvo-Produktionen, es steht in Gefahr, abgewürgt zu werden von fremden Kräften. Ja, ihr kennt es, seit Folge 1 beschäftigt uns ja auch schon unsere Aufnahmesituation. Jetzt hätte man ja in 250 Folgen das Ganze optimieren können. Zugegebenermaßen war es zwischendurch ja schon mal richtig gut. Es war gut. Mittlerweile ist es wieder sehr schlecht. Jetzt wurde hier, also ich glaube, das Mietverhältnis hier in diesem Studiokomplex, in dem wir jetzt sind, wurde aufgelöst. Und die ersten Steckdosen wurden, das ist kein Scheiß, abgedreht. Jetzt, wir sitzen zehn Kilometer auseinander, wir können uns noch sehen so gerade. Ich nur, weil ich meine Brille aufgesetzt habe und so ein Fernglas hier neben mir liegen habe. Und ja, weil wir noch eine Steckdose gefunden haben, die noch Saft hat. Ja, wir sind Podcast-Nomaden, ihr müsst euch das immer so vorstellen, wir haben immer so einen Säckel an so einer langen Stange dabei, an so einer Tonangel, wie wir den immer mit uns rumtragen und wir suchen durch die Stadt, durch die Parks, durch die Gänge, durch willkürlich Häuser, wir klopfen immer mal an, weil wir einen dringenden Raum brauchen, um einen Podcast aufzunehmen, die meisten wissen nicht, wovon wir reden, aber mittlerweile haben wir uns eingenistet gegen das Gesetz. Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn innerhalb dieser Aufnahme hier so eine große Abrissbirne. Nee, genau. Die rennt durch die Wand. So ein Presslufthammer oder sowas, einfach mal da durchkommt, weil die Bilder, hier wurden noch alle Laptops mitgenommen, alle PCs und es hängen keine Bilder mehr an den Wänden. Ja, so eine Sprengung drei, zwei, und wir versuchen noch so schnell rauszurennen und sind tot.
Weil wie genau wird wirklich nachgeguckt, ob noch Leute in dem Haus sind, bevor es abgerissen wird. Ich finde es auch erstens das und ich finde es auch immer albern, wenn die dann noch so sagen mit ihrer Tröte, dann so Sprengung in drei, zwei. Ja, jeder Mensch, der das hört, hat nicht in drei Sekunden die Möglichkeit, noch zu fliehen, sagt Sprengung um 15 Uhr. Ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht, wie ich darauf reagieren soll. Wenn ich das mal höre, Sprengung in drei, da will ich das mal für einen Scherz halten oder so, ich würde jetzt jedenfalls nicht sofort aufspringen und wegrennen. Halbe Sekunde ablachen, halbe Sekunde, Moment mal, stimmt das wirklich, nochmal eine Drittel Sekunde ablachen. Ja, bei mir wäre erst mal zehn Sekunden lang Kopfhörer aus dem Ohr friemeln und in diese Erfurt-Schachtel. Ich habe nichts gesagt. Ich will das erst mal neben dir sitzen in Frank. Was haben Sie gesagt? Ich habe nichts gesagt. Ich habe nichts gesagt. Ich habe gar nichts gesagt. Aber hier wird gesprengt. Hier wird gesprengt, Abrissbirne, aber auch einer der besten Jobs der Welt, oder den ganzen Tag die Abrissbirne. Wieder so ein Job, wo ich glaube, man stellt sich den besser vor als, ich glaube, es ist viel Warten, viel Warten auf Leute, die das Haus nochmal durchsuchen, sind wirklich alle raus, dann sitzt man da mit dieser riesen Kugel an diesem riesen Kran, eh, der die ganze Zeit, in meinem Kopf kann ich mir das gar nicht vorstellen, der die ganze Zeit umkippt, umkippen müsste, weil diese große Kugel da vorne, die hält ja unmöglich dran. Das heißt, man ist eh die ganze Zeit quasi gegen das physikalische Gesetz aufgelehnt hinten. Ich glaube, das Highlight ist, alle Woche schließen sich fünf Abrissbirnen-Bagger zusammen und tun ihre Kugeln so nebeneinander und machen dann so dieses Impuls-Erhaltungs-Ding, dass sie alle fünf Kugeln so aneinander schlagen und dann geht immer die letzte Kugel so weg.
Ich dachte, so Power Rangers-mäßig
schließen sie sich zusammen zu einem Riesen-Abriss-Bomber.
Das ist einmal im Monat.
Das ist einmal im Monat passiert,
das einmal in der Woche machen sie diese fünf Kugeln so
Tuck, Tuck, Tuck.
Geht das?
Klar.
Oder ab einer gewissen Größe dann nicht mehr.
Ich weiß es nicht, an die Abrissbirnenfahrer und Fahrerinnen da draußen,
bitte meldet euch.
Beschreibt den Energieerhaltungssatz. Wir fügen euch auf jeden Fall zusammen, wir organisieren das gerne und machen das. Ich glaube aber, dass generell, falls ihr euch fragt, habe ich einen coolen Job, ja oder nein? Ich glaube, jeder Job, der einen Countdown beinhaltet, ist definitiv auf der besseren Seite, ist auf der besseren Seite, ist auf der besseren Seite. Ich glaube, es gibt wenig langweilige Jobs, die einen Countdown beinhalten. So, jetzt ist die Frage. Deadlines sind ja auch eine Art von langweiliger Countdown. Ja, aber alles über fünf Minuten ist dann schon so, ja, bin ich runtergezählt. Ja, aber jetzt würdest du ja schon deinen Job, quasi bei den Rocket Beans Moderator zu sein, würdest du ja schon zuzählen. Ja, immer schon die fünf Sekunden und die letzten drei leise. Fünf, vier. Was? Go! Du hast aufgehört zu zählen bei vier. Wie bei King's Speech. Es gibt so manche Filme, wo ich so einzelne Gesten immer wieder nachhunde. Da gibt es auch so die Szene, wo die, nee, das ist nicht King's Speech, ich glaube, das ist Magnolia oder so. Ich glaube Magnolia, wo die so auch diese Quiz-Sendungen haben und dann zählen die so. Und dann zählt er mit der Hand fünf runter, aber die letzten drei sagt er nicht mehr und zeigt dann so drauf und das immer wieder, wenn jemand irgendwie nicht so vorankommt, wenn er spricht, dann mache ich immer so fünf, vier, drei, go! Und dann zielst du so an, auch wie so ein Wrestling-Richter. Ja, manche Leute brauchen so lange und überlegen und dann einfach mal so ein gut gemeinter Counter und kann da auch wirklich helfen, dass man einfach sagt so drei, zwei, eins, los.
Wobei man ehrlich gesagt sagen muss, was mich immer wieder ärgert, es gibt so Situationen, die immer und immer wieder erklärt werden, obwohl sie keine Erklärung bedürfen, wie zum Beispiel immer dieses, okay, aber auf die gedachte Null. Also ich zähle runter und auf die gedachte Null und jeder sagt immer, ja natürlich, worauf denn sonst? Auf die Eins. Es muss nie erklärt werden. Nein, das stimmt nicht. Doch, es wird immer noch nie, habe ich wirklich mitbekommen, dass da eine echte Diskussion entsteht, man sagt, okay, ich zähl runter. Und dann aber auf die gedachte Null. Und es ist so, ja, selbstverständlich auf die gedachte Null. Man betont auch, dass man die Null nicht sagen will. Niemand will die Null aussprechen, weil die Null ist keine Zahl. Ja, das ist ein bisschen wie so ein Voldemort-Szenario. Aber weil auf die gedachte Null nicht sagen will. Niemand will die Null aussprechen, weil die Null ist keine Zahl. Das ist ein bisschen wie so ein Voldemort-Szenario, aber weil auf die gedachte Null nicht sagen. Die Null nicht sagen. Also, gesagte drei, gesagte zwei, aber nicht gedachte Null. Und nicht minus eins denken, auf gar keinen Fall. Eigentlich, weil die Idee ist ja nur, dass man gleichzeitig Neujahr feiert, nicht zu früh, schon auf der Eins, das bringt dann vielleicht Unglück, keine Ahnung, aber die gedachte Null, dass man das so betont, warum, man sagt ja dabei auch Null. Nein, das ist vor allem unnötig, es ist absolut unnötig. Ich glaube, das Problem ist, dass die Null offiziell keine Zahl ist und wenn du in deinem Counter eine Null wie weiss keine Farbe ist, sowas und der Daumen kein Finger, ist die Null dass der Daumen der Farbe Weiss? In gewisser Weise schon. Und deswegen ist es problematisch, aber auch da immer dieses, oder es ist auch so, wenn irgendwie ein Glas runterfällt und es kaputt geht und so, niemand bewegt sich, niemand bewegt sich, Achtung, Scherben und alle so, ja, das habe ich schon hundertmal erlebt, dass ein Glas runterfällt. Ich war schon in deiner Position. Und immer muss es erklärt werden, immer müssen alle sagen und jemand sagt, ach wirklich, darf mich nicht bewegen? Ich dachte, ich stampfe hier einfach mal Open-the-Saints-mäßig paradig durch die Küche. Habe ich tausendmal geprobt. Ich war schon in der Position des Runterschmeissers, des Beworfenen, des Ignorierers, des Glases, vielleicht des Glases. Gedanklich war ich schon in der Position des Glases. Wir haben diese Situation schon tausendmal geprobt, durchgemacht und wieder geprobt. Und jetzt vielen Dank an den einen Helfershelfer, der dann immer sagt, keiner bewegt sich. Achtung, Vorsicht, keiner bewegen! Man könnte in die Scherben treten, nicht barfuß drüberlaufen. Ja, warum soll ich jetzt mit den Socken ausziehen? Das ist wirklich auch so eine Situation, niemand braucht die Anweisung, aber es ist dabei. Aber das beruhigt mich manchmal so ein bisschen, zu wissen, dass wenn Ausnahmesituationen passieren, Leute kümmern sich. Ja, jemand hat es im Griff, obwohl ich mir auch denke, vielleicht fallen mir überdurchschnittlich häufig Dinge runter. Vielleicht bin ich zu sehr Experte in der Situation gerade, weil viele Leute haben doch so einen angsterfüllten Blick im Sinne von Moment mal, das passiert, wenn ein Glas herabstürzt. Es zerbricht in tausend Einzelteile, die mich töten. Das ist das Geräusch und haben wirklich so ein, ja so fast so ein paranormales Erlebnis, wohingegen ich völlig d'accord damit bin. Ja, es ist auch die Frage, also welche Dinge
kann man sagen in gesellschaftlichen
Situationen und welche werden dann
wiederum, also die sind ja sehr offensichtlich,
so etwas zu sagen wie, keiner bewegt sich,
nicht barfuß drüberlaufen,
wohingegen sowas wie, niemand
darf Scherben jetzt erst essen.
Niemand darf die Scherben essen,
niemand darf sie in seiner Hand zerknüllen.
So, das wäre auch zu viel. Da würden alle im Raum sagen, ja, ach nee. Es ist ein ganz schmaler Grad zwischen Dingen, die obviers genug sind.
Ja, aber dass man sich nicht bewegt. Aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe tatsächlich auch schon unschöne Situationen erlebt mit zerbrochenen Flaschen, weil ich bin ja ein begnadeter Badewannengänger und ich habe eine komplex entwickelte Technik mittlerweile und essentiell war der Punkt, an dem ich gemerkt habe, wenn du in die Badewanne gehst, hat immer Wasser parat. Trinkwasser, ich rede nicht von Badewasser, das ist Lektion eins, die ich hart, hart lernen musste, die ersten zwanzig Bäder komplett trocken und dann habe ich gesagt, nee, so funktioniert das nicht. Aber ganz wichtig, immer zwei Flaschen Wasser dabei zu haben.
Zwei Flaschen?
Zwei Flaschen, glaub mir, wirklich, du hast, du dehydrierst komplett, weil du schwitzt ja auch, glaube ich.
Also das ist ja schon so ein Ding, weil wenn du nur so halb in der Badewanne sitzt, merkst du, der Oberkörper fängt an zu schwitzen.
Und du denkst dir, schwitzt dann der Unterkörper auch, also das, was im Wasser ist? Oder merkt man das nur nicht, weil es direkt ins Wasser gepumpt wird?
Weil der Körper ist ja nicht so dumm, dass er sagt, Leute, jetzt schwitzt und er sagt, wir sind im Wasser.
Das ist ein sehr guter Mensch. dann der Unterkörper auch, also das, was im Wasser ist? Oder merkt man das nur nicht, weil es direkt ins Wasser gepumpt wird? Weil der Körper ist ja nicht so dumm, dass er sagt, Leute, jetzt schwitzt und er sagt, wir sind im Wasser. Bringt das überhaupt was? Die Idee von Schweiß ist ja, dass der Schweiß kondensiert. Und dadurch wird Energie entzogen und die Haut abgekühlt. Aber unter Wasser wird das ja nicht passieren. Weil da ist ja alles voller Wasser, also weiß ich nicht genau. Schwitzen Fische? Richtig, also wenn so ein Hai ankommt, also ich stelle mir in solchen Situationen immer vor, wenn so ein riesiger gelber Fisch mit zwei Scheren rechts, zwei Scheren links, so einer Shotgun auf dem Kopf, einfach der härteste Jägerfisch der Welt und dem ging immer so eine Sardelle, die einfach sagt, ich bin einfach schlank und schnell, aber sonst nicht. Und ich glaube, die spricht komplett den Schweiß aus.
Ja, ich glaube auch. Jeder sind diese Tropfen, diese Klischee-Tropfen an den Stirn, diese Anime-Tropfen. Vielleicht ist es aber auch so eine schützende Schicht Schweiß, die sie noch schneller werden lässt. Eine was, eine schützende Schicht Schweiß? Schützende Schicht, Sardellenschicht. Kann sein, aber auf jeden Fall, du verlierst wahnsinnig viel Wasser und deswegen musst du trinken. Jetzt ist es aber so, ich verabschiede mich langsam aber sicher von der Plastikflasche.
Es ist ein langsamer, sehr, sehr schmerzhafter Abschied.
Und umarme die Glasflasche und habe deswegen Glasflaschen neben der Badewanne stehen auf den harten Fliesen. Der eine oder andere mag vielleicht hier schon erahnen, wohin diese kleine Geschichte aus meinem Alltag hinführen mag.
Oh nein.
Und dazu kommt natürlich noch, ich bade generell im Dunkeln.
Vielen Dank. Wohin diese kleine Geschichte aus meinem Alltag hinführen mag. Oh nein. Und dazu kommt natürlich noch, ich bade generell im Dunkeln, Stockdunkeln.
Das heißt folgende Situation, ich trinke genüsslich, stockdunkel, sehr heiß. Du merkst aber auch hier schon, dass du Herr deiner Probleme bist.
Richtig. Ja, ich bin Herr, Initiator und Countdown-Chef meiner Probleme.
Und ich trinke natürlich, wollte die Glasflasche neben mir hinstellen auf die Fliesen, sie kommt mir aus, sie rutscht aus, weil ich voller Schweiss bin, Wasser, alles glitschig, glibberig, sie kommt mir aus, sie zerschellt auf den harten Badezimmer Fliesen. Jetzt muss man sich das, wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also sind Scherben ins Badewasser gelangt? Nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht das Problem. Das Problem war, neben der Badewanne im Badezimmer entstand jetzt ein tödliches Minenfeld von Scherben. Nicht bewegen! Nicht bewegen, nicht barfuß hinüberlaufen. Richtig, das waren die Dinge, die mir sofort in den Kopf schossen. Was einem auch in den Kopf schießt, Farkiere. Richtig, allerdings, es war stockdunkel und der Lichtschalter ist auf der anderen Seite des Badezimmers, nicht auf der Seite der Badewanne. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt barfuß, nackt gar, einmal durch das Badezimmer warten, ohne zu wissen, wo die Scherben sind, weil es ist ja stockdunkel. Und für einen kurzen Moment lag ich in der Badewanne und dachte, das ist Schachmatt, das ist das Ende. Das ist das Ende und vielleicht bleibe ich jetzt hier einfach auch drin. Ja, weil allein aus der Badewanne rauszusteigen, erfordert ja, dass du einmal dein gesamtes Gewicht auf den einen Fuss legst und wenn da eine Scherbe ist, aus. Achilles, Sehne, Wunde, Spreiss, Füsse, geblutet. Richtig. So, wie hast du das Problem gelöst? Erstmal, wie bist du es angegangen? Erstmal dachte ich mir ... Weil ich bin bei solchen Situationen geneigt, diesen Moment kurz zu begutachten. Ja, ich hatte ja Zeit. In seiner Schönheit zu drehen, um mir vorzustellen, was wenn denn nie endet. Weil diese Momente, die sind selten da. man hat sich gerade komplett schachmatt gesetzt, was mache ich jetzt
und irgendwie bin ich da kurz zu Hause
in diesem Moment. Richtig, man kann kurz
die Schuhe ausziehen und sich dort mal aufs Sofa
legen und sich überlegen, was ist, wenn das wirklich das
Ende ist, wenn das der letzte Akt,
wenn das die Pointe
meines Lebens ist, wenn alles,
was ich hier gemacht habe, auf diesen Moment
zufließt und es hier aufhört.
Und dann dachte ich mir, Achtung, Florentin, denk an das, was dir beigebracht wurde, in Notsituationen, denk an die Normalverteilung, denk an die Wahrscheinlichkeit. Der Ort der größten Scherbenanzahl ist ja der, wo, das Epizentrum ist ja da, wo die Flasche zersprang. Sprich, und das war ja direkt neben der Badewanne, das heißt, meine Idee war, der Badewanne, der B ganz klar sagen, die offen sind? nochmal diesen Moment geniessen, weil hat man nicht so häufig. Ja, schwierige Entscheidung, da kann dir niemand helfen, da musst du selber durch.
Und wo sind jetzt, das frage ich mich wirklich, wo sind dann jetzt die Leute, die einem ganz klar sagen, die offensichtlichen Dinge sagen?
Genau.
Wo sind die, bitte nicht die Schuhe aussehen, bitte nicht drüber laufen, Leute jetzt?
Ja.
Weil in solchen Situationen vermisst man sie, hätte man sie gerne.
Wo ist jetzt Melly?
Wo ist Melly, die klar sagt, was zu tun ist?
Und ich dachte mir, gut, aber das Sprungmanöver hat einen weiteren Nachteil. Ich bin ja nass. Glitschig, rutschig. Okay, dass du dein Badezimmer nass machst, oder was? Ach so, dass du ausrutschst. Dass ich ausrutsche und dann nicht nur auf den harten Fliesenboden krache, sondern der ja auch noch momentan noch mit Glasscherben gesprinkelt ist. Also das wäre der Worst Case, ich spring aus der Badewanne, rutsche aus, schlage mit meinem gesamten nackten Körper auf die Fläche, wo die Glasscherben verteilt waren. Ganz ehrlich, man könnte, finde ich, für mich eine Doku machen, so Free-Solo-artig, über diesen krassen Free-Climber, der ohne Sicherung hoch in die Berge und auch, glaube ich, auch so richtig krasse steile Abhänge erklimmt. So eine Doku könnte man machen, einfach über Leute mit nassen Füssen in Badezimmern. Für mich hätte das einen ähnlichen Adrenalinkick. Absolut, absolut. Ist für mich eins zu eins das Gleiche. Es ist eine schwierige Situation. Und jetzt dachte ich mir, was passiert mit den Füssen, weil genau wie die Finger schrumpeln ja auch so ein bisschen, verschafft mir das mehr Reibung, mehr Grip. Ist das wie so eine Art, so ein Gartenhandschuh, der einen dann wirklich fest pinnt quasi auf den Fliesen. Und ich habe relativ schnell dieses Sprungmanöver verworfen. Was ich gemacht hätte, ist, ich wäre auf den Badewannenrand gestiegen.
Meiner ist breit genug, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist. Dann hätte ich langsam versucht, mich auf einem Bein zu bleiben, das andere Bein Richtung Waschbecken zu bewegen und dann langsam mit beiden Händen versucht, nach unten zu hangeln. Oh, Boden abzutasten, um dann aber auch direkt auf beiden Handflächen sich langsam reinzulassen, um Gewicht zu verlagern. Angenommen, du hast jetzt einen Fleck betastet mit deinen Händen, woher weißt du, dass dein Fuss genau diesen Fleck wieder trifft? Was du willst, äh, Muscle Memory, denn was du willst, ist ja auch, ähm, möglichst deine Kraft zu verteilen auf dem Boden. Ja, was du willst, Muscle Memory, denn was du willst, ist ja auch, möglichst deine Kraft zu verteilen auf dem Boden. Was du willst, ist nicht ein kleiner Punkt, auf dem du dein ganzes Gewicht hast, sondern maximale Verteilung. Ich habe eine ähnliche Idee, Stichwort Waschbecken. Ich dachte mir, schaffst du einen Sprung aufs Waschbecken. Klammer dich an dem Waschbecken fest und du bist der Gefahrenzone entkommen.
Die Frage ist natürlich dann, was passiert, wenn ein durchaus wuchtiger, nasser, nackter Mann mit einem durchaus mächtigen Satz auf ein Waschbecken kracht.
Was passiert dann? Hält ein Waschbecken das aus? Wie viel muss ein Waschbecken aushalten?
All diese Fragen haben dazu geführt, dass ich es gelassen habe und dann habe ich gedacht, wie kann man Licht machen? Kann man irgendwie Licht machen? Ich habe ja Wasser, heißes Wasser zur Verfügung, ich habe Haare, Hautfetzen, kann ich irgendwie ein kleines Flämmchen erzeugen? Problem aber auch, sehr viel Feuchtigkeit, sehr viel Feuchtigkeit. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht so der Romantik-Bader, der irgendwie eine Kerze am Bad hat, mit Feuerzeugen. Das wäre natürlich das absolut Beste gewesen. Deswegen dachte ich mir, chemische Reaktionen Phosphor, Magnesium, Kalk, ich hätte vielleicht Kalk zur Verfügung, kann ich daraus was machen, geht das in die Richtung, auch relativ schnell verworfen. Und dann habe ich aber versucht, mit einem Tarzan-esken Klettermanöver versucht, auf die Toilette zu kommen. Also aus der Badewanne, und das ist ein Stück, das ist ein Stück. Aber hast du auch hier mal noch mal geschafft, die Vogelperspektive einzunehmen und zu denken, was mache ich mit meinem Leben? Ja, absolut. Das war ein Moment.
Der Moment, wo man nackt auf seiner Toilette steht, während der Boden voller Scherben, gleichmäßig mit Scherben bedeckt ist, in einem stockdunklen Badezimmer.
Ist das ein Moment, wo man mal kurz überlegt, ob das so richtig ist, was man gerade macht?
Das war tatsächlich mein Überlebenswille, weil ich dachte mir, so kann es nicht enden.
So kann ich nicht enden, ich will nicht, dass das das große Feuerwerk, das Todesfeuerwerk meines Lebens ist.
Ich war allerdings ein bisschen froh, dass es stockdunkel war, weil ansonsten hätte ich die gesamte Misere im Spiegel gesehen. Ja.
Hätte ich diesen wuchtigen, nassen, ungelenken, eingeschrumpelten Körper mit dem traurigen Gesichtsausdruck gesehen.
Und ich bin dann rübergeklettert aufs Klo, dachte mir, das Klo hält alles aus.
Das muss 500 Kilo schwere Menschen aushalten, anders als ein Waschbecken.
Das muss alles aushalten, das klappt.
Habe mich einmal rübergewuchtet, es war eine Twister-Situation, ausgebreitet bis auf den Toilettendeckel, konnte mich rüberhangeln, bin draufgestanden und bin von da mit einem grossen Satz auch nochmal runtergegangen, möglichst weit vom Epizentrum weg, Füsse unversehrt. Füsse unversehrt, Lichtschalter angemacht, wunderbar, Situation geklärt. Gute Scherben liegen heute immer noch da, aber man muss ja dann auch nicht übertreiben, aber so bin ich rausgekommen aus dieser schweren, schweren Situation. Ich habe überlebt. Fantastisch. Ich habe überlebt. Eine sehr schwierige Situation und du hast es bravourös gemeistert. Ich habe das Frühstücksfernsehen angeschrieben, ob da eine Interviewmöglichkeit gelänge, ob man da sagen kann, hey, ich erzähle von meinem Drama, was mir passiert. Das kann ja jedem passieren. Ja, genau. Und sehe ich auch spannend, wenn es irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Claudia Schiffer, entschuldige meine Referenzen aus den Achtzigern, aber bei dir jetzt vielleicht nicht so spannend, also für das gemeine Frühstücksfernsehmpublikum.
Ich habe aber überlegt, ich würde die Story gerne verkaufen.
Also es ist ja immer...
So als diese... Oh, man kann ja im Internet Bilder verkaufen, ne?
Ja.
Wer sind die NFTs?
Ach so, ja.
Können wir nicht Anekdoten auch verkaufen?
Gerne, gerne. Die Anekdoten-Chain, Blockchain, wir bürgen dafür, dass es nicht einzigartig ist, weil man muss ganz ehrlich sagen, Promis, Interviews, ich bin immer mehr vom Glauben abgefallen. Als Kind, du sitzt bei Wetten, das und denkst dir, ah geil, da kommen die und reden die und die haben für ein tolles Leben. Aber irgendwann merkt man, die haben nicht wirklich was zu sagen. Die kommen oft in die Sendung, wenn sie ein Buch geschrieben haben oder ein Album und dann wirklich viel zu erzählen haben die nicht. Es ist auch nicht so wie dieser amerikanische Ethos, wo man sich vielleicht mal was überlegt und gemeinsam eine Anekdote irgendwie so aufbaut, so Stand-up-Comedy-mäßig, sondern oft so ein Ja, okay. Und ich glaube, da braucht es heiße Anekdoten. Und da würde ich gerne jemandem anbieten, also wer auch immer zuhört, ich verkaufe diese Anekdote, ich bin bereit, sie selber herzugeben und nehmt sie euch. Und dann darf die irgendwer dann in den deutschen Late-Night-Shows, wie wir sie ja zahlreich haben, erzählen. Ja, letztens habe ich angeschaut, es gibt eine neue Late-Night auf dem Late-Night-Himmel Deutschlands, ich bin ja großer Fan des Genres Late-Night und bin immer wieder gespannt, wie es neu interpretiert wird, was macht man, ist ja eigentlich ein recht starres Format, Stand-up, Talk, Einspielerspiele, kennt man alles, aber dann immer wieder so ein paar neue Einsätze und jetzt gibt es eine neue Late Night und zwar von Bibel TV. Es gibt die Late-Light-Night-Night-Night-Late-Light-Light-Show, glaube ich, oder Light-Night. Bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher. Es ist auf jeden Fall eine christliche Late-Night. Und noch nie habe ich so schnell auf den Player-Button gedrückt. Ganz ehrlich, ich bin angefixt, hochtausend. Das dachte ich mir. Das ist doch geil, weil das ist schon mal eine coole Idee, eine Late-Night mit einem Thema zu haben. Oft sind Late-Lights ja einfach, ja, ein cooler, lustiger Typ oder Frau ist jetzt irgendwie so am Anfang der Karriere, kriegt eine Late-Night, weil da kann man sich mal so ein bisschen austoben. Ist der Sidekick der Holy Ghost? Der Sidekick ist ein brennender Busch, was erstmal eine geniale Idee ist. Wait a second. Ein brennender Busch ist schon mal der beste fucking Late Night der Welt. Aber so Muppet-ähnlich?
Nee, es ist tatsächlich, ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen mit Bildeffekten gemacht,
es ist aber ein Busch, der halt wirklich auf dem,
der hat so einen eigenen Stuhl neben dem Schreibtisch.
Jetzt entschuldige, da bin ich nicht so bibelfest.
Was hat denn der brennende Busch?
Der brennt, naja.
Da brennt der Busch.
Das Problem ist halt, als Bibelautor hast du ein wahnsinniges Problem,
denn dir ist verboten, deinen Hauptcharakter darzustellen. Du darfst kein Bildnis zeichnen. Du kannst nicht sagen, ja, der hat halt so vier Arme und irgendwie so coole Raketen. Aber Jesu darfst du ja. Ja, aber Jesu ist ja auch eher dein zweiter Teil, so erster Teil ist ja der interessante. Und deswegen überlegst du halt, wie könnte man dieses Wesen darstellen, ohne es jetzt irgendwie zu vermenschlichen.
Brenner Busch ist das schon ganz geil.
Aber haben die eine Orgel als Band?
Eine Orgel als Band, also das ist schon ganz geil.
Brenner Busch als Zeitkick erstmal, war Brenner Busch cool.
Und ansonsten halt auch wirklich viele Salbungen auch, viele Kreuzgags, also wirklich alles schon durchgemacht und absolut grossartig. Der Teleprompter ist so eine grosse Steintafel, wo alles abgelesen wird, richtig cool. Und nein, leider ist es nicht ganz so, es ist sehr hip, es ist sehr jugendlich, es sind jugendliche Christen, was immer schon mal ein Kuriosum ist, jugendliche Christen. Bisschen angsteinflössend auch. Bisschen angsteinflössend und grundsätzlich denke ich mir immer, die Idee, eine thematische Late Night zu machen, ist super. Wir haben das ja auch sehr genossen, diese ganzen Mittelalter Late Night, Eiszeit Late Night. Genau, The History of Late Night haben wir über gute Arbeit gemacht. So eine thematische Late Night zu machen. Und das ist ja eigentlich eine geniale Idee, zu sagen, Late Night ist ja ein sehr allgemeines Format, kann man ja füllen, womit man will, aber zu sagen, also wenn jetzt irgendwie es hiesse, der Deutsche Imkerverband macht eine Late Night, wäre ich sofort dabei. Ja. Sofort, weil du weißt, okay, das ist ein Thema, alles geht um die... Aber wäre das nicht eine Idee für eine Late Night Show, dass man sagt, Everything is a Late Night Show, und man einmal macht quasi, jede Woche hat man ein anderes Thema und machtzifische Late-Night-Show für ein sehr spezifisches Publikum. Fände ich total gut. Sehr gut recherchiert. Wahnsinnig gut recherchiert. Wahnsinnig unzugänglich jede Woche aufs Neue. Ja, es gibt ja so verschiedene, auch Instagram-Accounts, die so den Humor aus ganz speziellen Ecken darstellen. Also so Wissenschaftlerhumor, Chemikerhumor, den man, und ich lese die immer ganz gerne, weil 80 Prozent der Post versteht gar nicht null. Aber man versteht es dann doch, glaube ich. Wenn man ein bisschen nachdenkt, kann man sich Situationen vorstellen, in denen das passiert und kriegt so einen Glimpse, wie es so sein könnte in dieser neuen Welt. Ich finde das ohnehin spannend, die Idee Humor, den andere verstehen, hat man selber nicht. Und es ist wie so ein Rätsel, weil Humor ist ja was sehr Intuitives, du liest es und du lachst sofort, weil du, ah okay, es ist sofort da, aber ich mag es auch, wenn es so ein Rätsel ist und du denkst, was könnte hier jetzt lustig sein, weil du siehst so einen schwarzen Bär und darüber so eine chemische Formel und dann irgendwie you versus the guy she told you not to worry about. Und du denkst dir, okay, jetzt, es ist Chlor. Du musst so wenig Reihen steigern. Wo läuft denn diese Late-Night-Show, wo kann man die sehen? Kann man die im Internet sehen? Die kann man sehen in der Mediathek von Bibel-TV. Und es ist merkwürdig, weil jugendliche Christen, finde ich auch ein bisschen furchteinflössend, und es ist ein bisschen merkwürdig, weil die sind so ein bisschen wie Jugendliche, die Jugendliche spielen. Aber es ist nicht total weird, dass man diese, ich habe auch Angst davor, wirklich Angst, und ich weiß nicht genau, woher das kommt, diese Angst, weil per Definition müssten die eigentlich wahnsinnig friedlich, Nächstenliebend und zuvorkommend und sehr ungefährlich sein. Ja. Was ist da schiefgelaufen eigentlich, dass man eigentlich Angst hat, weil es doch ein bisschen was Radikales hat, oder? Vor allem das Problem ist halt, du sagst einerseits, wir machen eine christliche Late Night, aber du musst immer irgendwie verstecken, dass es irgendwie christlich ist, weil es nicht so cool ist. Aber du musst es auf eine gewisse... Also ich hätte es viel besser gefunden, wenn die einfach all in gehen. Wenn die wie gesagt Brennerbusch, Kreuz, Moderator hängt am Kreuz, eine Sintflut beendet die Sendung. Wirklich alles halt all in Bibel, so richtig so, Alter, wir mögen den Scheiß. Wir haben da Bock drauf, wir finden das gut. Und da wäre ich sofort dabei. Aber das Problem ist, dadurch, dass die so jugendlich cool machen, müssen die das immer so verstecken, immer so. Und dann immer so, ah nee, das ist trotzdem cool. Also nicht weil wir Christen sind, das ist cool, sondern wir können cool sein, obwohl wir Christen sind. Das finde ich immer schade. Machen die denn so ein allgemeines Stand-Up oder machen die so, da bin ich Kirch-Stand-Up? Null Kirch. Null Kirch. Das Problem ist, Bibel-TV ist ja auch nicht gleich die Kirche. Die Kirche hat Anteile an Bibel-TV, aber da gibt es auch so Produktionsfirmen, die teilweise deren Programm beliefern, die kirchennah sind, aber es ist nicht eins zu eins und das ist irgendwie so eine Jugendorganisation. Ich verstehe das Problem. Und auch hier BibelTV, Shoutout, das kann mehr sein. Also wenn man da all in geht, glaube ich, kann das total cool sein.
Richtig cool. Mein Problem ist natürlich auch, ich habe den angeklickt und hatte ein paar Fragen an die Sendung. Und eine Frage ist natürlich, wie selbstironisch sind die? Weil das ist natürlich die grosse Frage. Weil Late Night sind per se immer selbstironisch. Du sagst immer, was für eine Strecksendung das ist, was für eine Schundsendung, wie blöd wir sind, kein Gast will ja mehr kommen. Das ist immer der erste Punkt. Du nimmst dich von Anfang an nicht ernst. Und wenn der Late Night sich zu ernst nimmt, dann bröckelt es schon, dann wird es schon schwierig. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, nein, die müssen all in gehen. Ich würde sofort anfangen, erster Gag ist ein Kindesmissbrauch-Gag. All in, wirklich sofort von der ersten Sekunde hier no bullshit. So würde ich reingehen, gar nichts, null, keine Selbstironie, kein Gag über, das finde ich so schade, weil damit, glaube ich, könnte man die Erwartungen wirklich brechen und sagen, ja okay, die sind auf unserer Seite. Ich finde, das ist nicht viel Potenzial. Das ist super viel Potenzial. Ich will es noch nachdenken, wie geil wäre das tatsächlich? Es wäre, glaube ich, meine Lieblingsländer schon im Fernsehen, wenn das heulingegangen wäre. Ich schaue dir auch weiter, weil es ist schon erstaunlich. Es ist sogar, wenn es so wahnsinnig hell wäre, also so irre, so heilig hell am Anfang und dann so, dann pendelt es sich langsam ein. Vor allem, es ist ja so ergiebig so, du kannst ja die ganzen Figuren auftreten lassen, irgendwie dann, allein so ein Breakdancenden Petrus oder so, das ist ja alles so viel einfaches Comedy-Politik. Auch die Gäste, die schreiben sich ja von allein. Die Gäste schreiben sich alle von allein. Johannes, der Täufer. Heute zu Gast. Johannes, der Täufer. Und dann die Georgel. Nee. Und dann so eine Konkurrenz Late Night vom Satan oder so, wo man sagt so, fuck, der hat uns wieder in den Quoten geschlagen oder so, ich würde all in gehen. Satan! Und dazu passend haben wir tatsächlich letzte Woche gerätselt, ob es in der Bibel Gags gibt. Die Bibel ist ja uralt und wie wir gerade schon gesagt haben, wenn du nicht drin bist im Thema, ist es super schwer Gags zu verstehen. Die Frage ist, gibt es Bibelforscher, die sich die Frage gestellt haben, könnten Dinge vielleicht lustig gemeint sein, auch in der Bibel? Und wir verstehen das heute nicht. Da haben wir einige Antworten bekommen. Wir haben tatsächlich ein großes theologisches Publikum dankenswerterweise. Und hier schreibt jemand, ja, der Gott des Alten Testaments war ein totaler Prankster. In Samuel 5, 1-4 klauen die Philister die Bundeslade, da sind die Tafeln drin mit den Geboten, und stellen sie in ihren Drachentempel, was schon mal fucking badass ist. Warum hören wir nicht mehr von den Philistern, dass sie einen Drachentempel haben? Als sie am nächsten Tag aufwachen, hat Gott ihre dort stehende Drachenstatue umgeworfen und sie stellen sie wieder auf. In der nächsten Nacht wirft Gott sie wieder um und lässt sie dabei kaputt gehen. Ja, aber ganz kurz, nicht aus so einem Prankster-Impuls, sondern aus so einem Punisher-Impuls. Der wird ja jetzt nicht das umschmeißen und nicht ins Fäustchen, in sein allmächtiges Fäustchen lachen. Ich glaube, ich meine vor allem, Gott hat halt auch als Option eine Sintflut. Die ist immer da, und ich stelle mir Gott vor, wie er sagt so, was gibt es da ein Problem, die haben was geklaut, Sintflut. Und die beraten so, sie können nicht jetzt jede Woche eine Sintflut machen. Sintflut! Die haben, nein, tut mir leid, mein Herr, die haben hundert Jahre gebraucht, um ihre Felder wieder aufzubauen, um ihre Städte wieder aufzubauen. Wir können jetzt nicht auf jede kleine Beleidigung mit einer Sintflut reagieren. Frösche regnen. Es regnet kaum noch Frösche. wir haben alle Lagerstäbchen voll mit Fröschen. Und also der schmeisst die Drachenstatue um. Ihr hättet sehen müssen, wie die Philister geschaut haben, als ihre Löwenstatue schon wieder einfach so auf dem Boden lag. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Widerspruch entdeckt. Da haben die Philister aber auch selber vielleicht ein bisschen Scheisse gebaut, wenn sie vor ihren Drachen... Widerspruch detected. Man nennt mich nicht immer sonst Detektiv, Stefan Tietze. Ja, Plasphemie detected. Ganz kurz. Dem geht es nicht um die Bundeslade, dem geht es um das... Euer Thema ist nicht einheitlich, ihr Idioten! Macht da doch eine Drachenstatue hin! Herr, mein Herr, Gott, Sie müssen nicht rufen, Sie sind allmächtig, Ihre... Ihr sind Sprachorganis... Ja, ich mich ärger's nur! Warum Löwenstatue? Mein Gott! Aber ganz kurz, wie viele boring Kackgeschichten ich gehört hab in der Schule, beim Religionsunterricht, für Konfirmation, Firmung, vorbereitet, nee, Konfirmation, Kommunion und Firmung, da hat man so einen Kirchenunterricht und hat so langweilige Kack-Stories. Wo waren die Philister? Wo waren die Philister mit ihrem Drachen-Shift? Ich glaube, das Problem ist, du willst halt nicht, dass die Religionslehrerin dafür verantwortlich gemacht wird, dass die gesamte Klasse zum Philistertum übergeht. Und wer sagt, wir wollen keine Christen mehr sein, was sind die Philister? Und die Rallye-Lehrerin so, nein, nein, stopp, nein, es gab nie Drachen, es gab keine Drachen. Nein, die hatten keine Drachen und Löwenstatue ist auch boring, oder? Leute, bitte, einfach alle konvertieren zu den Philistern. Und finde ich auf jeden Fall eine gute Story. Ich glaube, das Problem als Religion ist ja, du hast dieses Schriftstück und musst daraus irgendwie eine Lebensweise machen. Und da sind natürlich Storys gut, die eine offensichtliche Moral haben. Wohingegen die Storys Gott hat die Statue geworfen, halt so ein bisschen so ein, ja, was lernen wir daraus? Wie kann man das in der, weil die, ich glaube die grundsätzliche Form ist ja die Predigt. Also da muss ja irgendwas eine Pointe am Ende sein und nicht einfach nur so ein, ich habe mal gehört. Ich glaube das alte Testament war voll mit, wenn du nicht, weißt du mal so eine Drohung, wenn du nicht daran glaubst, bestraf dich Gott. Wenn du an Drachen glaubst oder an Löwen glaubst, eins von beiden, bestraf dich Gott. Wenn du wie die alten Ägypter zu den alten Göttern betest, dann regnet es Frösche und der Nil wird rot. So, ja. Ich weiss nicht, ob das Pranks sind, ganz ehrlich gesagt. Ja, es umschmeißen.
Also eine Statue umwerfen ist schon süß.
Weil stell dir mal so eine Statue vor, wie die wieder aufzustellen, wie nervig das sein muss.
Wo packt man die an, am Arm? Geht die kaputt? Löwe? Na, beim zweiten Mal ist die kaputt gegangen. Oh. Aber hat Gott eine neue besorgt, oder war dann so ... Er steht dann plötzlich mit so einer großen Schleife so eine Drachenstatue da. Und er so, ach was, das ist ja nett. Auch ein bisschen ärgerlich. Vielleicht mag er die Idee auch nicht, dass deren Drachengott total cool damit ist, dass man ein Abbild von dem macht. Gott an sich aber zu eitel ist und diese Regeln ins Licht geworfen hat, dieses, nee, macht keine Bilder von mir. Auch Eifersucht. Ja, Löwe wäre schon cool, oder? Warum haben wir das, sorry nochmal,
warum haben wir das gemacht, mit dem du so als kein Bild hast?
Sie wollten das, Sie sind zu eitel dafür.
Was heißt eitel?
Aber ich kann es komplett nachvollziehen übrigens,
weil ich habe das Gefühl, dass
unsere Fanart
nicht mitaltert,
sondern auf den Bildern beruht
von mir von vor fünf Jahren.
Und
ich sehe immer noch so aus wie damals,
ich sehe mittlerweile aber nicht mehr so aus,
Aber das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. altert, sondern auf den Bildern beruht von mir von vor fünf Jahren. Das stimmt.
Ich sehe immer noch so aus wie damals.
Ich sehe mittlerweile aber nicht mehr so aus.
Aber das Fanart altert nicht.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt so auch ein Gottkomplex hätte,
würde ich vielleicht auch sagen,
nein, ich wünsche keine Artbilder von mir.
Das stimmt, ja.
Man ist nämlich selten zufrieden.
Aber wir könnten so viel Geld verlieren mit Merch.
Bitte Gott, überlegen Sie sich das. Wir könnten Tassen machen,
Schlüsselanhänger, allein ihr Gesicht
Vielen Dank. Stimmt, ja. Man ist nämlich selten zufrieden. Aber wir könnten so viel Geld verlieren mit Merch. Bitte Gott, überlegen Sie sich das, wir könnten Tassen machen, Schlüsselanhänger, allein ihr Gesicht, das reicht schon, wirklich so ein Marmor, so ein Mosaik. Aber die treffen mich nicht, die Leute treffen nicht mich. Ich sehe mich nicht in den Bildern. Ja, aber stellen Sie sich vor, wie viele Frösche wir uns leisten können von dem ganzen Geld. Achtung, Idee, Mosaik. Wir bringen jede Woche ein Mosaikstück raus und wenn die Leute jedes kaufen, können sie es am Ende zusammensetzen und ihr Gesicht drauf. Wo man dann jede Ausgabe kaufen muss. Ja, das ist doch gut, wie viele Frösche wir uns leisten. These, Gott ist scheissen hässlich und deswegen will er nicht, dass Abbilder von ihm gemacht werden. Ja, oder Gott ist halt Vishnu. Er ist halt wirklich dieser Elefant mit den acht Rüsseln und sagt halt, die können mich nicht sehen, weil Hinduismus hat schon hingekriegt, aber
der hat irgendwie Schluss gemacht, weil die
kamen ihn blöd. Und jetzt hat er gesagt, wir machen
Christentum hier, ich schicke euch mein Kind.
Und die dürfen halt nicht wissen, dass es
eigentlich derselbe Gott ist. Kann auch
sein. Die Kirche ist sehr lustig,
weiter geht's, jemand hat uns auch geschickt, und zwar
im Alten Testament, Genesis 18,
10 bis 15, für alle, die das kurz nachschlagen
wollten, um sich abzuroffeln. Ich höre doch jetzt schon
die Seiten schlagen. Die Gold
Vielen Dank. Weiter geht's, jemand hat uns auch geschickt und zwar im Alten Testament, Genesis 18, 10-15, für alle, die das kurz nachschlagen wollten, um sich abzuroffeln. Ich höre doch jetzt schon die Seiten schlagen. Die Goldseiten. Kommt Gott zu Abraham und Sarah und sagt ihnen. Moment, ist das so geschrieben? Kommt Gott, da war so einer, da durfte mal irgendwie so der coole Volo, durfte da mal selber ein Kapitel schreiben. Der Praktikant von Matthäus zu schreiben, du den Scheiß mit Sarah, das interessiert mich nicht. Kommt Sarah zu Jesu. Kommt Gott zu Abraham und Sarah und sagt ihnen, dass sie in einem Jahr ein Kind bekommen werden. Sarah lacht und denkt, ich bin doch schon alt und verbraucht und mein Mann auch. Gott findet das auch lustig und antwortet, tja, ich bin allmächtig und du kriegst ein Kind. Der klassische, ich mach die alte Frau schwanger Prank.
Also, auch hier darf gelacht werden.
Nee, ehrlich gesagt, testet ihr doch das Ding Glauben.
Wenn das die Gags sind, die ihr uns schickt aus der Bibel, dann haben wir ja recht.
Aber es soll auch Wortspiele geben, wo er sagt, Simon der Fischer, na, na, na, kennen wir alles. Und der sagt zu seinem guten Kumpel Petrus, auf dir werde ich meine Kirche aufbauen und nenne dich ab jetzt Petrus. Petrus ist eine abgewandelte Form des griechischen Wortes für Stein, er nennt ihn quasi Rocky. Die Ironie daran ist, dass Simon aber gar nicht stabil ist, sondern ständig zweifelt, als würde das dicke Kind der Gruppe Usain Bolt nennen, weil es einmal schnell gelaufen ist, als der Eiswagen kam. Da kommt auch viel eigener Humor durch an der Stelle. Also aus der Mail kommt mehr eigener Humor durch als viel Humor. Ich glaube, die Idee ist, dass du den, der am meisten zweifelst den Stein nennst, den Felsenen. Aber es gibt eine, wer hat das geschrieben? Weil ich glaube, da gibt es eine Fernsehsendung für ihn, wo er gerne mal mitschreiben kann. Lord Denty heißt er bei uns hier auf der Webseite. Herr Lord, also ich glaube, Bibel TV und du, es wäre ein Match. Ja, aber auf jeden Fall. Aber sowas würde ich mir wünschen. Aber wie geil, Simon der Fischer, Johannes der Täufer, wo ist das hin? Leute auf ihre Tätigkeit und dann Simon der Fischer auch so, ich war einmal fischen damals. Ich habe da nicht mehr wirklich viel gefragt. Ich bin Schreiner. Wenn mir ist mein Handy ins Wasser gefallen und ich bin kurz in Badehose ins Wasser gegangen, um das rauszuholen, es war kaputt, seitdem nennen mich alle Simon der Fischer. Simon der Fischer, du bist Simon der Fischer! Ich bin Schmied vom Beruf, ich mach euch eure ganzen Kutschenräder und den ganzen Quatsch. Aber irgendwann hieß er halt nur noch Simon Fischer. Joseph der Zimmermann war es ja auch. Ja, irgendwann nur noch Joseph Zimmermann. Ja. Der ist dann irgendwann weggefallen eigentlich. Du wärst Stefan der Tietze.
Was ist ein Tietze? Weiß man
nicht. Ist verloren gegangen.
Vielleicht man könnte, in der Bibel
hieß du Stefan der Tietze.
Und alle so, was macht er?
Ja, manchmal tietze ich halt so.
Ich tietze euch. Ich tietze rum.
Was ihr wollt, ich tietze euch.
Ich tietze rum. Aber das sind alles, Leute,
schade, es lief jetzt die erste Folge der Late Light Show auf Rül TV und ich hoffe, dass die wirklich nochmal... Bisschen sperrig, der Titel. Ja, wenn du ein Wortspiel im Titel hast, ist kompliziert, aber ich hoffe, dass sie das Floss noch rumreissen, die die Arche noch mal rumreissen und ab Folge zwei einfach ein bisschen mehr auf Bibelgags machen, weil ich glaube, darum geht's. Das war die erste Folge jetzt. Ja gut, da muss man den Zeit geben. Absolut. Das Problem bei Late Nights ist immer, die erste Folge ist immer schlecht, weil die ja so ein bisschen davon leben, dass man eine Gewohnheit reinbringt, dass man aufbaut und man schaut es jede Woche an und ah, okay, man hat den Ziel irgendwann verstanden. So als Einzelfolge ist es ja immer schwer zu bewerten. Deswegen, ich bleib dran, guck's an. Wir bleiben dran und gucken's uns an, find ich gut. Ja, ey, das ist spannend. Vielleicht ist es aber wirklich eine Idee, mal zu sagen, wir machen eine monothematische Late-Night-Show. Find ich auch nicht schlecht. Also find ich wirklich gut, aus so einer gewissen Sparte heraus. Ja, so was Wissenschaftliches, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht irgendwie Physiker oder halt was Historisches wirklich. Ja, vielleicht was Historisches. Historisches oder halt komplett eine Star Wars Late Night geht natürlich auch halt in so einem Nerd, in so einer Nerd-Ecke gibt es natürlich auch die Late Nerd Show von Orkenspalter zum Beispiel, ist keine klassische Late Night Show, aber wo man auch so ein bisschen in dieses Comic Pen and Paper Thema reingeht und so, aber halt so mit Showcharakter wäre eigentlich gut. Mit Showcharakter wäre eigentlich gut. Ich bleib dran, ich bleib dran, ich kann Bericht erstatten. Es ist natürlich leicht, sich über Jugendliche Christen lustig zu machen. Ich hoffe, da werden es nicht Leute hingehen und die beleidigen. Manchmal ist es aber auch nicht so leicht. Das ist nicht nötig. Das ist natürlich, es ist alles ein bisschen sperrig, aber ich meine, man muss ja auch mal anfangen mit sowas. Der liebe Kollege Donnyo Sullivan hat neulich auch malulich auch mal die Churchies gefunden, eine christliche Hip-Hop-Gruppe, die, und das ist unfassbar, was das für eine, die füllen riesige Hallen, deren Videos sind unglaublich krass produziert, das ist unwahrscheinlich. Also das ist so eine Welt, die man da kurz betreten hat. Ich habe mich da richtig ein bisschen reingefogst kurz. Aber sind die Deutsche oder Internationalen? Deutsche, das sind Deutsche, die Churchies. Das sind, glaube ich, zwei Brüder und die reimen, also machen Hip-Hop. Kirche auf Kirche. Wenn es gerade uncool klingt, liegt das an meinem fehlenden Vokabular des Hip-Hops für Hip-Hop, aber dies ist ziemlich krass und es sind auch richtig gute Beats und ich glaube gute Texte, also im Sinne von Hip-Hop. Ich weiß nicht, inhaltlich finde ich es tatsächlich ein bisschen schwierig, weil es dann natürlich dann, wenn es, da wird es dann teilweise vielleicht so ein bisschen radikal, weiß ich nicht, ich habe es nicht genau unter die Lupe genommen, aber die Churchies, und dann habe ich auch echt Angst, dass die, keine Ahnung, irgendwann vor meinem Haus zu stehen. Ich habe tatsächlich einfach Schiss vor jungen Gläubigen. Ja, es ist eine merkwürdige Szene irgendwie, aber es ist interessant, weil die haben auch in der ersten Folge von dieser Late-Light-Show eine richtig grosse Influencerin bekommen, die so um die eine Million Follower hat auf Instagram. Ein Auftritt von der würde wahrscheinlich normalerweise mehr kosten als das ganze Studio irgendwie. Aber die kommt da wahrscheinlich relativ günstig oder sogar kostenlos hin, weil die halt auch auf dieses Glaubensthema Bock hat. Also du kriegst halt auch Leute, die vielleicht über dem Status deiner Sendung wären, einfach weil die da einfach Bock drauf haben. Oder schiebt da die Kirche mal ein bisschen Budget rüber. Boah, das weiß ich nicht. Da verkaufen die so ein krasses Relikt, irgendwie die Krone von Krösus. Ja genau, die kriegen dann irgendwie so einen Zahn von irgendeinem Heiligen, kriegt dann diese Influencerin angeboten. Relikte. Aus der Kapelle, das ist ein echter Zahn. Wow. Das ist tatsächlich das Brustbein von einem der Heiligen drei Könige. Wir wissen nicht, von welchem, aber es ist von Kaspar, Melchior oder Balthasar. Und ja, ich habe schon den rechten Schenkelknochen, wenn ich jetzt auch noch das Brustbein habe. Auch drei geile Gäste, echt so. Ah, geil. Kaspar, Melchior und Balthasar, finde ich mega. Die finde ich richtig gut. Heute mit Kaspar, Melchior und Balthasar. Oder Balthasar konnte nicht kommen oder irgendwie sowas. Nee, konnte nicht kommen, einen Flug nicht bekommen. Und die vielleicht, genau, die sind nämlich zu Gast, sitzen auf der Bank und die zerstreiten sich während des Interviews. Und dann so richtig Drama, haben keinen Bock mehr. Und dann kommen so richtig die alten Probleme nochmal hoch und die trennen sich live während der Show. Läuft einer weint von der Bühne, haut ab, die anderen müssen auch noch awkward.
Kasper hat Mürre mitgebracht.
Genau, sie müssen wieder schenken.
Wir haben ein kleines Geschenk, wir haben doch gesagt, keine Geschenke, du mal mit deinen
scheiss Geschenken.
Du hast ja mit scheiss Mürre immer, kein Mensch weiss, was Mürre ist.
Nein, danke, ich nehme das vielen, vielen Dank, nein, das ist doch Bullshit.
Ja, okay, wenn wir so anfangen, ich habe Gold mitgebracht.
Du hast, wir haben gesagt 15 Euro. Aber auch immer dieselben Probleme, man kann eine ganze Staffel füllen mit diesen Gags. Late Night Show, bitte, bitte, bitte, ihr müsst die Arche rumreissen. Reist die Arche rum. Aber allein die Arche. Ein Spieler aus der Arche kannst du immer machen, zwei Esel, wo du sagst, wir sind beide Weibchen, oder? Kann sein. Diese Vollidioten. Aber wenn die das erfahren, dann werfen die uns über Bord. Ja, ja, nee, nee, dann muss... Und sprich tiefer, sprich ein bisschen tiefer. Vielleicht aber wenn so ein Pferd oder so.
Ist nicht Pferd plus Esel?
Gleich mehr. Genau, das ist so eine Highschool. Dann müssen sie sich zu den Pferden schleichen und müssen da gucken, dass zumindest eine von den beiden schwanger wird, damit sie es aufrechterhalten können. Tolle Geschichte. Dann den Maria und Josef Test machen. Eine Schwangere und ihr obdachloser Mann müssen gemeinsam von Tür zu Tür gehen und gucken, wer sie aufnimmt. Ja, super. Mit so einem Mikrofon. Und dann, das ist auch so Rappen-Gefahr-mäßig. Ja, das finde ich richtig lustig. Das finde ich auch. Das finde ich eine gute Idee. Dann natürlich auch so Sketche. Maria bei so einer Trash-Talk-Show mit Vaterschaftstest, so Maury-mäßig. Mit Schattenwand und allem. Sie ist sich nicht sicher, ob Joseph der Vater ist, weil das Kind irgendwie ganz anders ist als er, sieht ganz anders aus. Offensichtlich ein Engel hinter der Schattenwand. Offensichtlich. Riesenflügel. Ja, wir haben einen Gast, der vielleicht mehr weiß. Ja, ich bin der Michael. Hi. Und dann Joseph, also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich der Vater bin, einen Vaterschaftstest. Bing, bing, bing, Joseph, du bist nicht der Vater. Ich wusste es, ich wusste es! Aber sie kriegen alle das Auto! What? Das kannst du machen, aber so Strassenumfragen, so Outdoor-Segmente, finde ich auch eine richtig gute Idee. Ich finde es, aber gut, jetzt erwarten natürlich sehr viel von der Kirche, Selbstironie. Ja, das ist, glaube ich, der Schlüssel. Wenn sie das nicht hinkriegen, dann wird das nichts, weil du musst dich nicht dafür schämen, finde ich. Das ist immer so dieses, ja, wir erwähnen zwar ab und zu das Wort Glaube, aber wir thematisieren es nie groß und das ist genau der Fehler. Du musst, weil dadurch ist es immer so ein Obwohl du musst sagen, nein, wir haben da Bock drauf, wir stehen da nicht. Eine gute Rubrik fände ich auch, kennst du die Show Take Me Out, die von Ralf Schmitz moderiert wird, wo sehr viele Frauen an Buzzern stehen, da stellt sich ein Mann vorne vor und die Buzzer, wenn er dann sagt, zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, ich stehe liebe Hip-Hop und dann buzzern Frauen, die keinen Bock haben, mit ihm auszugehen. Das mit sehr vielen Messdienern und vorne einem Pfarrer. Ja, sehr gut. Das finde ich sehr. Ja, sowas muss sein. Take me out, aber halt ganz viele Messdiener. Oder Next auch. Wo so ein neunjähriger Junge und dann kommen so fünf Bischöfe und er darf alle zehn Minuten daten. Ja, oder Bachelor. Der Bachelor Bachelor? Der Bachelor. Finde ich auch gut. Diese ganze, Adam und Eva. Der kleine Dennis, ich habe keine Rose für dich. Man muss der kleine Dennis, er ist sehr viel im Mestiger und Einfahrer. The Preacher. The Preacher Man. The Preacher Man, finde ich auch gut. Adam und Eva, wie geschrieben eigentlich für die Sendung? Für Naked Attraction. Naked Attraction, richtig gut, da kannst du so viele Sachen machen. Naked Attraction, aber er hat dann Eva und einen Apfel. Und er weiß nicht, wohin er sich mehr gezogen fühlt. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Die Schlange als Sidekick wäre natürlich auch mega geil. Auch nicht mehr mehr gewesen. Die Schlange als Sidekick, die ist bissig, die ist richtig bissig, die ist sassy und die will immer den Moderator verführen, einen Apfel zu essen. Und er sagt, na jetzt komm, wir machen gerne. Der liegt da die ganze Zeit auf dem Tisch, liegt ein Apfel. Und die Kamera auch immer so zoomt so langsam auf den Apfel und der Moderator muss immer, Leute, jetzt, wir machen die nächste. Wir machen die nächste Rubik, denn wir haben gleich noch zu Gast. Alles dreht sich eigentlich nur um den Apfel die ganze Zeit. Ja. Grossartig. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Schlangen ist ein guter Sidekick, brennender Busch, finde ich, ist ein supergeiler Sidekick. Ich verstehe die Reprennen, ich freue mich nicht, aber ich freue mich sehr. Hat der nicht irgendwie dann die zehn Gebote gesagt oder so, weiß ich nicht. Der brennende Busch? Ja, so ein brennender Busch. Ich erinnere mich grob an einen brennenden Busch. Da kommt auch das Sprichwort, da brennt der Busch. Da brennt der Busch auch. Aber ich weiß es nicht genau konkret, ich könnte es nicht Vers und Psalm nennen. Ich weiß auch nicht mehr ganz genau, wo es ist, aber könnt ihr alle mal googeln. Aber so One-Liner sind Psalm, also dann schön, ja genau, die Psalme. Lustig, Psalm der Woche. Der Psalm der Woche, ja. Das finde ich auch gut. Da kann es wirklich weniger. Also, im Ernst, Leute, da ist eine Menge. Da ist eine Menge drin. Ich fände es echt schade, wenn ihr das alles ungenutzt liegen lasst. Gerne auch, also ruft uns an. Wir hätten auch mal eine Folge. Wir machen euch gerne eine Folge. Wir machen euch eine Folge. Wenn die letzte Folge, wenn ihr sagt, wir sind nicht zufrieden mit der Sendung bis dahin, die Quoten sind schlecht, gebt uns die letzte Folge, wir gucken, was wir daraus machen. Es gibt eine Moderatorin, einen Moderator, machen wir alles, überhaupt kein Problem, übernehmen wir alles mit eurem Team. Mit eurem Team schreiben wir, wir sind so Rachter-Restaurant-Tester-mäßig. Genau, die Late-Night-Tester. Danach ist es noch schlechter als davor. Danach ist es sehr schlecht, läuft nicht.
Und in einem Jahr kommen wir zurück, um das zu besuchen.
Und es gibt es abgesetzt inzwischen.
Naja.
Wir haben letzte Woche auch darüber gesprochen,
über das Thema Arthouse-Filme und dass man,
wenn man zu weirdes Stilmittel gewohnt ist,
dass man manchmal Filme falsch schaut mit der falschen Tonspur.
Wie wir beide mit The Young Pope slash The New Pope, die wir teilweise lange auf Italienisch schauen, weil wir denken, ah, das muss man jetzt nicht verstehen. Turns out, Untertitel waren nicht eingestellt. Ein sehr schönes Beispiel für dieses Thema hat uns Leonard geschickt, mit einer fantastischen Geschichte, und zwar meinte er, ich und ein Freund reden sehr oft über Monty Python-Filme, er kannte aber die Filme von Terry Gilliam nicht. Ich als Cineast wollte ihn natürlich einführen, mache Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas an, hatte den vor vielen Jahren mal gesehen. Nachdem der Film schon fünf Minuten läuft und der Bildschirm immer noch schwarz ist, während Musik läuft, sagte mein Kumpel, dass vielleicht das HDMI-Kabel kaputt ist. Ich, ein Filmkondisseur erster Klasse, mit einem ekelhaften Selbstbewusstsein, nein, nein, das ist Gilliam, der geht Filme eben etwas anders an. Stellt sich raus, hat ein I-Kabel war tatsächlich kaputt und hat das Video nicht übertragen, habe ich dann erst nach zehn Minuten gemerkt. Wie richtig gut. Wie sieht ein schwarzes Fassbildschirm aus? Aber wie unangenehm danach auch dieses, ich will dir einen tollen Film zeigen, ich kenne mich aus. Das ist wahnsinnig unangenehm. Kann ich das ein bisschen ihr mir auch wissen. Ja, das wäre mir exakt so passiert und irgendwann muss man es feststellen und es wird immer schwerer. Wenn man sich auch hasst rückblickend, aber solche Momente, die machen einen, glaube ich, zu einem besseren Menschen, weil davor ist man ja wirklich so hochnäsig und sagt, die nehmen dir dann die gesamte Arroganz einfach auf einen Schlag. Ich kenne Gilliam, ich kenne Terry, ich weiß, wie Terry dreht. Terry, das ist ein Spielmittel, dessen er sich häufiger benutzt. So ist man ja, das denkt man ja wirklich. Man ist ja dann so. Und dann plötzlich nimmt einem das alles. Das ist total geil. Nee, das hat ihm E-Kabel. Einfach so ganz auf den Boden gebracht. Aber allein auch die Vorstellung, sie hätten den gesamten Film in Schwarzbild. Weil ab einem gewissen Punkt kannst du ja nicht mehr sagen, sag mal, es kann sein,
dass wir so dumm sind, dass wir jetzt eine halbe Stunde
Schwarzbild angeschaut haben, ohne es zu müssen.
Irgendwann ziehst du es durch und schaust den gesamten
Film an und hörst einfach nur zu.
Ah, cool. Sehr cool.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade bei Filmen sind, es läuft
nämlich aktuell bei uns
bei Instagram, ihr könnt es in dem Highlight-Reel schauen,
das GIF-Festival.
Festival.gif Leidenschaft in 50 Frames. Glamour, roter Teppich, Stars, Promis, Sternchen, alle zu Gast auf Instagram beim grossen GIF-Festival. Denn die anonym bleibende Jury aus hochkarätigen Filmschaffenden GIF-Experten entscheidet jede Woche über die jeweiligen Gewinner aus den jeweiligen Kategorien. Wir hatten
jetzt schon Best Drama
ist aktuell. Ja, Best Drama läuft,
könnt ihr euch angucken in den Instagram-Stories,
aktuell die nominierten zum Thema Best Drama.
Und letzte Woche war Best Animation.
Best Animation waren fantastische
Sachen dabei und die Jury hat sich entschieden
für das GIF Too Slow.
Richtig toll. Tolles GIF. Ein Dinosaurier, ein trauriger Dinosaurier, grossartig, schaut es euch an, finde ich fantastisch. Finde ich fantastisch, da kommen noch ganz tolle Sachen, die Jury ist hellauf begeistert, ob der interessanten Beiträge. Da kommen allerdings nicht nur positive Dinge, es kann auch sein, dass eine grosse Flutwelle an Kritik auf uns heranprasselt, denn es gab schon den ersten Eklat dieser prestigeträchtigen Veranstaltung. Ja, es gibt den ersten Eklat und da müssen wir uns auch als Veranstalter, natürlich dürfen wir uns nicht aus der Verantwortung ziehen, denn Emil hat das fantastische GIF eingereicht, ich will mit. Ja, und es ist leider Gottes allerdings, Ton zu hören.
Richtig, er hat eine kleine Dramaszene, meisterlich komponiert für uns mit Bild und Ton.
Und das funktioniert nur zusammen.
Wir wurden allerdings relativ schnell darauf hingewiesen, dass Gifs ja keinen Ton haben können.
Es gab einen Shitstorm.
Eine Nachricht.
In der sehr engen Giftfestival-Community.
Sagen wir ein Shit-Lüftchen. Ja, ja, Brise. Shit-Brise. Wir hören es einmal. Ich will mit! Genau, das ist der Skandalton, der die Runden gemacht hat. Eigentlich klingen so keine Gifs, Gifs klingen eher so. Genau, still, denn sie haben keinen Ton. Denn sie haben keinen Ton. Gifs haben keinen Ton. Und ja, es ist uns durchgerutscht ein bisschen. Es ist streng genommen auch nicht in einem Gif-Format eingereicht worden, sondern in einem MP4. Also da sind Fehler, Fehler wurden gemacht. Und wir als Veranstalter möchten uns dafür entschuldigen und müssen Emil leider disqualifizieren. Und ja, aber die anderen Nominierten sind nach wie vor da, sind toll und für die kann die Jury jetzt noch abstimmen. Emil, du bist raus, du konntest nicht mit, du bleibst zurück, du bist raus. Aber ich habe, es ist natürlich gut, wenn du keinen Ton hast, ist natürlich eine grosse Erleichterung für alle Übersetzer dieser Welt, die Gifs übersetzen müssen,
müssen ja auch international übersetzt werden.
Und ich habe immer, ich weiß nicht warum, aber ich habe oft,
wenn ich einen Film anschaue
und eine gewisse Szene schaue, denke ich mir
viel Spaß, Übersetzer.
Viel Spaß, das zu übersetzen,
vergiss es.
Das dachte ich zum Beispiel bei Family Guy,
cool whip,
say cool, cool, say whip, whip, say cool whip, cool whip. Da dachte ich mir auch so, ja viel Spaß, liebe deutsche Übersetzer, das zu übersetzen. Stell sich raus, perfekt, Schlagsahne, sag Schlag, Schlag, sag Sahne, Sahne, sag Schlagsahne, Schlagsahne. Funktioniert genauso. Mit dem gleichen Wort einen ähnlichen, sehr, sehr vergleichbaren Sprachfehler anzudeuten. Fantastisch.
Der auch sogar Sinn ergibt. Es gibt Leute, die sagen Schlagsahne. Und es funktioniert. Es ist grossartig, perfekt übersetzt. Ich glaube, es gibt ein Wort, das der absolute Albtraum für Übersetzer ist. Und ich glaube, wenn du als Übersetzer ein Skript bekommst, ein englisches, wäre mein erstes, das allererste, was ich machen würde, Command F ist Apfel S und dieses Wort eintippen, ob das im Skript ist. Und wenn es im Skript ist, dann bin ich verloren. Ja. Dann habe ich, dann würde ich wirklich... Du hast gespeichert gerade mit Command S, aber ich verstehe was... Ach F, Command F, Entschuldigung, ich habe es abgespeichert. mal absprechen, das ist immer gut, kein schlechter Impuls. Es ist immer ein Reflex, immer Apfel-S, alle fünf Minuten, aber du hast völlig recht, Apfel-F und dann gebe ich folgendes Wort ein, Stoned. Stoned ist ein riesiges Problem. Bekifft. Bekifft, sowas high, benebelt, aber zum Beispiel unser allerlieblings Film-Franchise, Flucht der Karibik, Teil fünf, hat folgenden Gag, Jack Sparrow soll hingerichtet werden mit einer Guillotine-Konstruktion und einer lustigen Szene, er läuft davon weg, furchtbar grauenvoll, grauenvoll Humor. Und dann nach dieser Exekution oder ich glaube davor sagt er, I'd rather be stoned. Ich wäre lieber gesteinigt. Oder eben der Wortwitz und jetzt fact. Und da dachte ich mir, vergiss es, weil gesteinigt und bekifft, vergiss es. Es ist einfach unmöglich. Als Übersetzer kannst du an der Stelle sagen, schneiden wir es raus, oder ich brauche einfach eine zwei Liter Flasche Whisky, um durch diesen Abend zu kommen. In Rum ertränkt sowas? Verstehst du, ertränkt, er ist gerne betrunken. Ja, aber das ist ja keine Hinrichtungsmethode. Stone ist ja wirklich gut. Du, ist schon klar, es geht nicht in gut, es wird nicht in gut funktionieren. Ich bin nur am Versuchen, zumindest einigermaßen mich an Strohlen festzuhalten. Ich glaube, es ist unmöglich. Ich glaube, es ist unmöglich. Und ich frage mich, ob irgendwann nicht die Gesellschaft der Übersetzer einen Brief an Hollywood schickt, mit der kleinen, aber feinen Bitte, vermeidet doch bitte diesen konkreten Wortwitz, weil wir kriegen ihn nicht übersetzt. Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Lasst esin ist Übersetzerin von englischer Literatur, was sehr spannend ist. Kannst du die mal fragen, wie sie diese Szene übersetzt hat? Das würde ich machen, ja. Und dann können wir bis nächste Woche auch mal gucken, wie es im deutschen Film übersetzt wurde, habe ich jetzt nicht parat. Aber können wir mal schauen, weil das ist glaube ich nicht so leicht, weil als englischer Autor machst du dir da überhaupt keine Gedanken. Ich schreibe ihr und du vergleichst parallel, wie es gelöst wurde und wir vergleichen, ob sie eine gute Übersetzung ist. Und wir können ja auch selber überlegen, ob uns eine gute Übersetzung einfallen würde. Nächste Woche lösen wir dieses kleine Rätsel auf, aber es ist echt so ein Ding, weil als englischer Autor machst du dir überhaupt keine Gedanken darüber, über solche Sachen, ob die übersetzbar sind oder nicht, weil es ist schwer genug, sich überhaupt ein Gag auszudenken und dann noch zu sagen, ja, bei der spanische Markt wird das schwer angeschlagen, ja, fuck it, mir egal. Ja, doch, ich denke da immer dran und ich freue mich da immer drüber, tatsächlich, wenn je unübersetzbarer es ist. Schaut mal, wie er das übersetzt, ihr Kasper. Ja, und tatsächlich, das Problem ist ja, ich kenne ja unseren Übersetzer sehr gut auch so und es ist auch total cool, mit dem zu arbeiten und der fragt auch häufig dann Dinge, wie er die übersetzen kann und dann versuche ich mit ihm daran, an Lösungen zu arbeiten, weil es ja so ist bei Netflix, wird es erst alles auf Englisch übersetzt und dann wird es von Englisch in die ganzen anderen Sprachen übersetzt, was es noch ein bisschen messier macht, weil jetzt ja der spanische Übersetzer, die spanische Übersetzerin muss ja mit mit dem englischen Ton arbeiten. Und der ist ja schon eine schlechtere Version als die deutsche Originalversion. Arguably. So, das macht es ganz ein bisschen schwierig. Und da war unsere Idee, mal in Untertiteln zumindest reinzuschreiben, weil wir haben sehr oft in der zweiten Staffel den Running Gag gehabt, dass Moritz Lenny korrigiert mit dem Genitiv. Er sagt dann immer, ja, wegen meinem Auto, wegen deines Autos. So, und dann haben wir, du musst ja der Übersetzer das übersetzen, was nicht funktioniert, weil es im Englischen gibt es diesen Genitiv nicht. Also haben wir unten in den Untertiteln in eckigen Klammern geschrieben, unübersetzbarer deutscher Grammar-Joke. Was lustig gewesen wäre, für alle lustig gewesen wäre. Unübersetzbarer German-Grammar-Joke. Und durften wir nicht machen. Hat Netflix verboten. Wirklich. Durften wir nicht machen. Das heißt aber, solche Sachen werden dann oft übersetzt einfach durch gar nichts, oder? Ich glaube, das wurde im Endeffekt dann durch gar nichts ersetzt, ja, durch nichts. Oder er sagt einfach ein falsches Wort und Moritz korrigiert ihn oder so. Oder schneidest du es einfach raus, weil auf Netflix könntest du die Version auch tatsächlich anpassen. Kürzer machen. Und solche Szenen einfach wegnehmen, wenn der Geist nicht durchkommt. Nee, es ist auf jeden Fall drin. Es wird nichts weggeschnitten. es wurde dann durch nichts ersetzt. Was nicht so schlimm ist, weil es kommen ja keine Lacher. Das stimmt. Bei Sitcoms hast du natürlich das Problem, das Lacher kommt an den Punkt, oh ja, stimmt. Ja, wo nachher das funktioniert. Ja, das ist sehr interessant. Also ich werde aber auf jeden Fall fragen, wie ich das über das hätte.
Schwierig.
Dann bleibt auf jeden Fall dran, ne?
Festival.gif? Ja, bleibt dran. Es ist bislang noch nicht so eine Hype-Welle entstanden, wie ich es eigentlich erwartet hätte. Nee, ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ihr könnt aber auch gerne die alten Nominierten nochmal angucken, die sind alle gespeichert worden, wir haben Instagram verstanden und könnt ihr alles machen. Verstanden würde ich jetzt nicht sagen. Nee, verstanden würde ich auch nicht sagen. Das ist wirklich schwierig. Wir sind da. Wir sind zumindest jetzt angekommen. Wir sind anwesend. Wir kommen aber erst mal noch an. Ich glaube, wir haben unsere Jacke irgendwo falsch hingehängt, wo wir eigentlich nicht hinhängen sollen. Wir sitzen in der Lobby. Wir sind angekommen. Wir sind sicher angekommen. Wir wissen nicht, wohin mit dem Rucksack. Wir wissen nicht Schuhe aus, Schuhe an, Schuhe aus, Schuhe an, Schuhe aus, Schuhe an. Wohin damit? Also was passiert da? Das sind alles noch offene Fragen, aber wir sind zumindest anwesend. Wir sind anwesend. Eine Stunde zu früh. Ja. Ihr seid nicht anwesend, könnte es aber nächste Woche wieder sein. Wenn es weitergeht mit das Podcast UFO, werden wir diese kleinen Übersetzungsproblematik auflösen. Ansonsten vielen Dank für eine Eicheländerung. Ich finde es so, dass du so einen Cliffhanger einbaust. Ja, natürlich. Richtig seriell und professionell. Dann bleiben die Leute am Ball. Vielen Dank für die Einsendungen von euren ganzen Bibelgangs. Es geht natürlich noch weiter und viel Spaß damit. Es wird fantastisch und vielleicht, falls es nichts wird mit BibelTV, machen wir vielleicht irgendwann unsere eigene christliche Lasershow. Unsere eigene BibelTV. Ohne christlich zu sein, aber das ist ja auch erstmal egal. Ja, bibel.io. So die moderne Variante. In Ordnung. Bibel in Ordnung, ja. Ich schaue mal rein bei Bibel-TV, unterstütze die Kollegen da, unsere Comedy-Kollegen. Motiviert sie zu anderen. Ihr müsst euch nicht darüber lustig machen oder die fertig machen. Es ist ein leichtes Ziel. Motiviert sie, lieber das besser zu machen. Und dann glaube ich, kann das eine richtig coole Sache sein. Oder können alle für eine bessere Late-Night-Show beten? Absolut, ja, wir können einfach beten.
Wir brauchen alle dringend bessere Late-Night-Shows.
Haut rein, macht's gut.
Gehen ab, Amen! Du suchst den Vibe, abseits vom Standard?
Willkommen im Ruhrgebiet.
Echt statt inszeniert.
Jede Ecke anders, jede Story echt.
Späti-Romantik an der Trinkhalle, Beats unterm Förderturm, Sonnenuntergang auf der Halde.
Klingt anders? Ist es auch. Dein Ruhrgebiet, wo das Unperfekte perfekt passt.
Inspiration für deinen Next-Level-Städtetrip gibt's auf Insta, mein.ruhrgebiet.